[Music]
cappella girls i'm one of those a
cappella boys and we're gonna have vodka
children
it's inevitable really drunk right now I
don't think at all your songs without
any instrument it's also on matters yes
when you came in and you were just
strumming the guitar and it was like
totally off-key I wanted to choke you I
just have to pull back because I am
limited because I have notes well at
least it's not herpes why do you have
that as well here's your official bu
rape whistle
don't blow it unless it's actually
happening what's your name fat Amy
um you call yourself fat Amy yes a twig
[ __ ] like you don't do it behind my
back seriously you girls are awesome
we horrible I hate you kill yourselves
girl power sisters before misters we're
gonna kick your ass I'm sorry I don't
speak no say what did you say she
actually speaks eight languages but Luis
is not one of them so I have a feeling
that we should kiss I mean correct I
sometimes have a feeling I couldn't do
crystal meth but then I think mm better
nah yeah
[Music]